I read about like half of those hey
everyone how's it going I hope you are
doing well so I wanted to talk about my
relationship with books and reading a
little bit so when I was little I
enjoyed reading I likes going to the
library I like checking out books and I
thought it was just generally like fun
and then high school rolls around and
then you have to read and then for me it
just became this thing that was like not
so fun anymore and that was just my
personal experience I still liked the
stories and I liked reading but yeah I
think reading just became this thing
where I had to read a certain amount of
pages or analyze them or write an essay
about them and so like the act of
reading was not so much for enjoyment
anymore as it was like let's get an A on
that essay so I can go to college which
obviously kind of really sucks because I
think reading should be fun and I was
definitely reading for the wrong reasons
throughout high school and then College
so when I graduated college and reading
was no longer mandatory I realized that
there was still a lot of books that I
wanted to read there were these worlds
that I want to be transported to and
lessons that I wanted to learn that you
can only learn through books but when I
started reading them I realized I was
paying much more attention to the page
number than the actual content itself
and then I was like oh no I don't know
how to read anymore what I mean weird I
mean like read for leisure and actually
read to read not read to do this other
thing so some of these books that I
really wanted to read were like big
beefy books that I thought were like
rite of passage like big classics or
self-help books but then I would buy
them and I would never touch them or I
would not get past like the tenth page
and just give up cuz I was like I can't
do it I can't read the page count this
is too hard I don't know how to like
read anymore although granted always
just really never that good at reading
comprehension that was like my lowest
SAT score and so then what I realized
like there was no way that I was going
to be able to read Pride and Prejudice
for fun I was like you know maybe I
should just start with something really
really easy so while I didn't go full
green eggs and ham
I started by reading a lot of young
adult novels but it was great because I
feel like there was really cool young
adult novels at the time Perks of Being
a Wallflower just ran into a movie so I
read that I read The Fault in Our Stars
because that was also becoming a movie
and then I started reading a bunch of
john green's other young adult novels i
thought about reading Twilight but I was
like I've read it before and I wasn't
gonna stoop to that level quite yet I
mean it's okay
Twilight's fine alright lights is very
engaging novel and and I'm like people
like vampires and stuff right yeah and I
was kind of like but these are books
that like middle schoolers and high
schoolers read and you know like a
college-educated adult now but I
realized that these books are like super
engaging and I would get through them
like within a week and I realize now
that young adult novels get a little bit
of a bad rep because of people like me
who are too prideful to read them yeah
like young adult novels actually really
did help me to get back into reading
because I remembered how awesome it is
to feel like you were so engrossed in a
story and you have so much of a personal
attachment to one or more characters the
best part of it all is that it
transports me back to when I was in high
school and that's kind of a cool feeling
going back to that time when you were
like Who am I and what am I supposed to
do in life and what do I even like and
trying to just make sense of yourself
and the world it's a cool time to kind
of revisit and think about because I
have a lot more answers now so since
then I feel like I regained my love for
reading and also just like a sense of
patience to get through a whole story
and now I'm realizing what kinds of
books I really like now that I feel like
I'm primed to read a lot of other books
I tend to gravitate towards fiction
novels and memoirs
I think fiction is great because there
are like whole worlds that maybe you
couldn't even imagine but other authors
did and diving into that and getting a
peek into how they imagine things is
like I don't like some cool and the
thing I really like about memoirs is
that like there's stories of real people
which is like some of these stories I'm
just like how like you can't make this
stuff up and so it's even more powerful
that way honestly this is like a journey
that I didn't expect to go on as an
adult but it makes a lot of sense after
like how I saw reading as
activity through high school in college
and just rediscovering what that means
for me as an adult and like I think
there's a lot of things I have changed
about me since like high school college
and now me as an adult so yeah let me
know if you'd like to know more about
these things about just like an adult I
guess and what it's been like to be an
adult for the last couple years leave it
in the comments down below so that's
been my journey for how I learned how to
read again so if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up and don't
forget to hit the subscribe button so
you don't miss any more videos I wanted
to say thank you to a sponsor that is
very fitting for this video which is
audible audible has the largest
selection of audiobooks on the planet
and I think it's pretty cool that
there's a service like this nowadays
that basically turns books into like a
podcast that you can listen to so
reading can be a little bit more of a
passive activity one of the young adult
novels that I've actually recently read
that I really recommend is Turtles all
the way down by John Green it's the
story about a teenage girl who's living
with OCD and it is so so good and I
highly recommend it and so you can go
listen to that on audible right now they
also have a pretty cool offer going on
right now which is if you're an Amazon
Prime member which I am and you should
be too because it's so convenient you
got audible for 495 a month for three
months and then 1495 a month after that
so it's basically like getting three
months for the price of one so head on
over to audible.com slash May you go or
text me go to five hundred five hundred
to get started this is your cue to go to
audible.com slash my eco or text when
you go to five hundred five hundred to
get started
cool I think that's it for today so I'll
see you next time bye
[Music]